do you lament those
years maybe that you could have gotten
that free time back and lived more
no the past is a fiction the past is a
fiction don't don't spend any time
thinking about the past it doesn't exist
it's not real yeah no one can get more
more advice than yeah or not completely
waste the time to think about the past
there's nothing there you can't go back
yeah maybe if you have some less some
important lessons to learn but you know
those lessons can be learned pretty fast
you can synthesize that data very
quickly there's no need to reminisce
upon the past i think people get trapped
a lot of people
are sorting out their past when the past
is just entirely contained in your head
it's not anywhere else
and so the easiest way is just to kind
of get over any problems or reinterpret
them in a way that it serves you
and just move on because the present is
all that actually exists you got that's
where you live that's where you exist
that's what you got to spend time on and
time within and any moment where you're
not present you're literally squandering
time so one so i had this thought today
actually coincidentally
which is
what is a good use of time
how should time be spent right how do
you know that you're getting the most
out of every moment and so then i was
like okay well i want the time to be
useful and engaging and i don't want to
be too mentally disturbed or anxious
while i'm in that time so what is that
well there's flow state i could be in
flow but flow the way that it was
defined narrowly in that famous book
i forget the author's name but it's like
a difficult russian or polish name but
so forgive me for that but the way flow
was defined in that book was
that you were engaged in a task at the
edge of your capability
where um it was you were good enough at
it that you could actually pull it off
but not so good at it that it wasn't
challenging to you so you're doing
challenging work at the edge of the
capability and that's flow and that's a
good use of time well that's like a
couple hours a day that's not good
enough what about the rest of my day
and so i thought about like really what
you want out of your time is you want to
be in flow every moment
and how are you getting to flow every
moment whether you're brushing your
teeth or walking the dog or reading a
book or speaking in clubhouse well
you have to do it in such a way that
you're completely engaged you're fully
aware you're completely present what
does that mean that means that your mind
isn't running out of control so
ultimately if you don't want to waste
time
your mind has to be under control and
you can't control your mind it's an
uncontrollable monkey now we're in
catch-22 land so all you can do is be
aware of your mind being out of control
because that gives you a level of
detachment from your mind that then lets
you be in flow so the very very subtle
answer to the very difficult question of
how you should spend your time the
answer is by being self-aware within
every moment
yeah i think a lot of people they try to
get better but
it's just
just
become more observant of who you are and
you will automatically just get better
like if you could or or you don't
but all you can control is just being
aware of what you're doing there's just
far too much going on where you were
born what languages you speak who you're
born to like there's so many variables
that that you know this present moment
consists of all you can do is just
observe as much of it as possible
well you are you are a play of a set of
infinite forces launched from the big
bang intersecting at this precise moment
your inputs into that and your ability
to control that are incredibly limited
if they exist at all
so the best thing to do is of course
function to the best of your capability
but just be as aware as possible as
self-aware as possible because you're
always aware of the environment around
you right so your your awareness always
extends in the environment the problem
is extends too far out into the
environment you lose your self-awareness
then your mind starts running crazy
you're constantly reacting to things
that the moment slips away from you
because you're lost in the past or the
future which don't really exist and your
time is wasted but if you are immersed
in the activity because your mind is
quiet or and generally it's quiet
because you're self-aware of it when
it's running around then there's a
certain level of flow state that you can
enter into your everyday life and that
is time well spent
yeah my little
like hack for this is just trying to
zoom in right like even the tiniest like
bite of food or sip of water or like
whatever can
be a deeply immersive experience and
pull you into the present well it's like
the first the first level was you know
100 free time and then the second level
is 100 fellow state
yeah i think that's right well yeah and
it doesn't the beauty is if you get 100
flow state it doesn't even have to be
free time so free time in a sense it's a
crutch it's a crutch because you don't
know how to be immersed in whatever it
is that you're doing and a truly uh
present person you know almost like in
enlightened buddha like being would be
perfectly happy whether he or she was
busting rocks in a chain gang
or you know playing video games or
sitting there and staring out of the
space
well it's it's
i i had to tweet today it said you know
we we often use this term at gumroad
like we want to help creators earn a
living doing what they love and i sort
of
joked like
the easiest way to make a living is to
or doing what you love is to fall in
love with making money
like if you love the act of doing it
then inherently you know like and it's
kind of the same with all of these
things you just fall in love with it
um
yeah
yeah i mean so what you're basically
saying there then is fall in love with
life itself which is hard for most
people to do it's not easy
so you either make life better so that
you fall in love with it or you
become okay with falling in love with
what you currently have like both i
think sort of and i think life is like
basically both of those things for
everybody to some degree well one of my
favorite tweets of all time is by
charlie knowles who i followed on
twitter for a while and uh
he tweeted that
at the end of the day you have to
believe that either everything is a
miracle or nothing is
and that's a very deep statement
basically if you believe in a single
miracle like for example if like
i don't know if the holy spirit just
popped up and performed one miracle in
front of you that means then there are
miracles everywhere because
you can't take anything for granted
everything has to be a miracle um or
you're completely atheistic and you
believe that there are no miracles it
was all just kind of random
but that one simple
that the answer to that one simple
question will basically define your
entire worldview but it has to be an
authentic answer unfortunately we're
mostly agnostic
so it's so easy to find out if you're if
you're happy which is like
you know at this moment everyone can ask
themselves like at this moment do i have
what i want would i change something
about this moment i personally would not
right now
then you're happy
and if
if there is a change that you you want
if you want it you can either stop
wanting it that's sort of maybe
preferred in the cheapest option
or you get what you want and then maybe
you you know you'd like those are just
the two outcomes it's kind of like what
you said you know life is what is it two
questions right what do you want and did
you did you get it
[Music]
[Music]
you